Pennsylvania congressman and pediatric
physician Tim Murphy his author of the
angry child it's a how-to guide for
parents on constructively disciplining
their children he spoke about it
recently for 45 minutes hello everyone
thank you for coming out tonight my name
is Darla shoemaker I am the marketing
manager that covers several of the
border stores and a couple months ago I
got a phone call from ms loriann HOF
Oberlin who's the co-author of the book
the angry child which was written with
congressman Tim Murphy and mr. Berlin
asked if we would be interested in
having an event to discuss topics about
how to help your kids with stressful
issues and how to help parents stay
saying over the summer when there's so
much going on and you're going in so
many different directions and it seemed
like the perfect topic for a lot of
frazzled parents who don't know which
way to turn so we're very pleased to
have with us tonight congressman Tim
Murphy he's been featured in numerous
including the CBS Early Show The
Washington Post USA Weekend all over top
talking about children's topics ranging
from ADHD - I think you've recently had
a bill talking about terrorism children
and terrorism there was also the use of
medication in the schools so all sorts
of issues that are very relevant and
very important to children in our
country it's congressman Murphy is a
great advocate for children and we're
just very pleased to have him with us
here tonight so please help me welcome
congressman Tim Murphy thank you
well I appreciate your stamina having
had some votes to see me I mean to rush
out here made it so late but I'm
thankful for so many of you hanging in
there you know I often times I'm asked
this question what is it Congress what
is a person who's a psychologist doing
in Congress let alone someone who work
with children and families all his life
and because as a as a psychologist with
children oftentimes dealt with issues of
Tantrums and whining and fighting good
match good match so it is although
certainly many of the many of those
things oftentimes happen if you ever
watch c-span you see what happens in
Congress so I get to continue to
practice but you know that aside for
that I've got to say though that the
people in Congress I've noticed and also
in my time serving as a state senator in
Pennsylvania are certainly very caring
for the most part people who really want
to do the right thing and really on both
sides of the aisle and where oftentimes
we do come together in both sides there
are issues that relate to children and
families but there is a lot that we can
do in government that helps children and
families and there's a lot that we
probably should have very little
business getting our hands involved in
and and those are things that take place
day to day with moms and dads and
dealing with those daily battles with
children and yet parents do need
assistance and understanding what to do
about those kind of daily battles to
take place and during the summertime
here or during any time you're really it
as a matter of when children are home
during the day they're not off to school
they're fighting and appearance at work
they come back and they hear kids
complaining on and on mom you won't
believe what Joey did while you were
gone and the whining and fights go on
and on where the calls during the day to
mom and dad at work can I do this can I
go there I know you said I couldn't but
and then negotiating and all those kind
of problem solving issues are trying and
take place add to parents stress during
the summer until you finally say I can't
wait till my kids go back to school but
be that as it may we still have a lot of
issues to deal with and any time during
the year that helps parents get a handle
on what they can do to stay sane while
their kids are trying to drive them
crazy and also how we can on the
positive side help parents and children
connect so that we can end up with a war
a culture where parents have do remain
in charge of their children where kids
are raised and happy and healthy
households and we're certainly parents
don't have to deal with a lot of anger
and rage now I know the title of book
here is angry child and and one of the
things that struck me lately in our
world
sadly there'll be times recently and
there times that'll continue to come up
when we find children who are plotting
to harm their peers to bring guns to
school to murder other people and that
is something that usually always makes
the headlines because of the shocking
nature of it and sadly sometimes we get
used to hearing those stories as tragic
as they are one of the things I've
always noticed when I've heard this when
you watch the interviews at a place of
parents as people will say I never knew
my child was capable of this I never
knew this was going to happen yes he may
have had sometimes as little stress or
had some interest in video games and
friends but we didn't have that
communication and whether your child is
one is gonna grow up to to be one of
those chonus serious problems or whether
it's just a matter of a child with some
of these daily battles the key comes
with a number of things we can do as
parents and so what I want to do during
this time is give parents some of those
cues of what can be done in planning
your life with your children so that
when proms do come up we have an outline
a format to to deal with it and what I'm
going to start off with is give you some
of these things these five seas as I
call them how to make choices to clarify
make the consequences how to communicate
and work towards consistency as an
outline as a framework of handling some
everyday problems with children to give
parents some ideas about Hamlet because
I believe very much that a lot of these
things the answer is not in the US House
the answer is in your house of what to
do so let me let me give this as an
outline of what to do first of all when
I'm in my work as a psychologist work
with families very often parents would
come to me and say I have this problem
with my child and they would name a
problem my kids not doing homework my
kid leaves my things out fights with his
sister they argue over the television
they leave dirty socks whatever it is
and
and each case one could come up with a
little formula we'll have you tried this
or this and generally what I found was
parents want to know tell me the right
punishment to use with my child or him
stand in the corner do I take his
allowance away do I give him money if he
does his chores do i ground him what do
I do and it is not just that punishment
that makes a difference with children it
is actually these five different things
that make a difference the first one
being choices now by choices I mean as
parents we cannot possibly deal with all
the things our kids do every day if we
did if we paid attention to everything
if every little problem percolated to
the surface we ourselves wouldn't be
able to handle the intense stress and if
you ever really want to measure this
someday during your child's day have a
little notepad with you and just mark
off every little tiny thing and chances
are pretty good as parents as a good
coping mechanism we just tuned most of
them out I mean there are times for
example I'm the father of a teenage girl
and I as a father of a teenage girl i
watch very closely what she wears all
the time my wife has probably begun to
to look away from some of that but
having been a teenage boy i watch very
carefully what my daughter wears when
she's trying to leave the house and she
knows that that will happen and probably
tries to slip out the front door when
I'm standing in the kitchen so I don't
see her but it is one of those things I
have made a conscious choice to be aware
of sometimes that is not such a big
issue for parents for me it is but in
any case what I recommend we do is you
have to look at if you make this master
list of all the things your children do
that you do or do not like look at it
this way what you want to see more of
what you want to see less of and what
you want to see stay the same now it's
real important we don't just focus only
on the negative because if you focus
only on the negative what will you be
doing all day
criticizing your child punishing your
child and your child will say mom dad
all you do is nag me all day and you
completely disconnect salesmen talk
about this idea that and people in
management talk about the idea that you
should compliment someone seven times
for every one time you're gonna
criticize him and as parents we forget
that we usually criticize him seven
times and maybe compliment them once and
Christmas we say well I still like you
the rest of the year you're driving me
nuts that's not gonna be helped
for kids it's important that they do
hear those positive things because it's
all part of building that relationship
and in that therefore it's important to
make a list of what you want to see more
of so in other words behaviors aren't
quite there but you're working on what
you want to see less of things your
child is doing now that you really want
to see them stop doing and what you want
to see stay the same is even the most
troublesome child has got some things
that they're doing that you want to keep
going and that's very important second
thing you do is you have to think about
in select you have to select out some of
these behaviors in the choices you're
making say if I want to change some
things what is my child really capable
of changing you may want to see your
child able to get themselves dressed in
the morning but if your child's - not
gonna happen
but believe me I've seen many a parent
very frustrated the three and four year
and five year old can tie their shoes
they can't get themselves dressed and
they get very frustrated as a parents
trying to rush off to work says what's
wrong with you why can't you do all this
well some kids are right in saying I'm
only four I can't do it yet and it's
importantly understand that so what
they're able to do what they're willing
to do what's appropriate for their age
once you've made some of these choices
the next thing you have to do is clarify
it again this is important but parents
we oftentimes miss this aspect by
clarify I mean you have to know the who
what when where why of that behavior it
isn't just a matter of I don't like it
so therefore I want to change that
behavior you have to decide if there's
something that's happening repeatedly in
your child's life or something they do
wrong perhaps it's good to know who else
is involved in that it isn't just what
Bobby does maybe his brother provokes
him into it a fake fight maybe his
sister's involved when does it happen
does this thing your child does it's
annoying happen at certain times of day
is it only after school for example that
your child seems to come to life like a
grizzly bear is it before meal time is
that perhaps you may find other reasons
for it
when you look at the winds many a parent
describes to me how the child is real
ornery and difficult when they come home
from school well is it because they've
had a tough day at school is it because
that they're being teased by other kids
is because they're hungry and they need
a snack is because they're tired because
they stayed up late knowing those kind
of details is very
but against again his parents oftentimes
we overlook it thinking only if my
child's not doing something I have to
come up with a punishment and if my
child is doing something I don't like I
have to come up with a punishment for
that not yet
sometimes clarifying it gives you enough
information to know what to do when I've
seen this myself many times because I
learn a lot even though I may have my
PhD in psychology parenting is a whole
other school I have a continuing
education credits every day and what
happens is I learn a lot sometimes I'm
doing things there with a sort of get
miffed it's something that my daughter
has done and Maurice's lay off this has
happened you need to know about this
rough day with the boys at school a boy
she liked is now dating another freshman
and she's upset about that it's not the
time to engage in a conversation with my
daughter about something about the way
her room looks it's good to just back
away discretion being the better part of
valor there too but once you've defined
a behavior in that way the next thing is
now it's time to figure out the
consequences but the consequences should
fit the crime or if you want to make it
happen more often the reward should fit
what you're trying to get the child to
do and you have to be developmentally
appropriate so again
grounding a three-year-old saying you
can't go or any friends houses or I'm
gonna hold you back from the prom is
really not gonna be that effective but
there are other things that can be done
and the traditional things like timeout
you sit in the corner you sit in the
chair for a few minutes that usually is
an effective strategy holding back on
desserts holding back from treats may
work well for a preschool child the same
kind of thing is probably not gonna be
the thing you want to do with your
twelve year old now you have to go sit
in the corner Bobby
Bobby's not gonna like that very much
but you can use other techniques such as
grounding such as rewards such as
checklist and even structuring such
things as an allowance schedule if what
you're trying to get the child to is
more of take more responsibility with
putting where things then having a
checklist for which they earn checks
towards their allowance makes a lot of
sense just like when you were at work
if you do your job your boss pays you
for that so - an allowance can be along
those lines it is an automatic that
Bobby gets five dollars a week for his
allowance but only if certain things are
done if he doesn't to him well that
money's deducted from his
income for the week so another technique
that sometimes parents can use as a
consequence is writing that is sometimes
writing out and the child write down
what they it could be I've known some
parents say well you seem to have
trouble with this certain life message
so what do you say we pick out this
really nice paragraph from a book a
moral less than a story Bible passage
whatever might be and maybe you should
write it about 20 times so we can really
imprint it on your mind
I know teachers having me do this when I
was younger and look I ended up writing
a book the but that's something else
that can be done however we're not done
we're not done just by having the choice
we made and clarifying them and coming
with the consequence the next thing
we've got to do is communicate that it's
extremely important you let the child in
on what you're trying to do and again
I've known many parents who have had a
great plan but forgot to sit down and
tell little Mary or Johnny what they're
trying to do or when their child has
done something wrong or done something
right have jumped to conclusions and
gotten hot-headed themselves or
ourselves instead of thinking us through
and handling it in a positive way so
along the communication lines I came up
with four little words to remember
request reason remind and respond and
that is if your child does something
wrong or is not doing something you want
them to do make a request Billy would
you please take care of that or remind
him of the rule hey Bill remember the
rule on this when you come on from
school what do you want remember please
just a hang up your coat take your
backpack I take it to your room he
always dumps it by the front door right
leaves of shoes everywhere it's a mess
if necessary the second door is give a
reason the reason could be its
cluttering up a step someone's gonna
trip over it plus if you do that I'm
gonna you know find you or something
else you're gonna give them the
consequences for that now you don't have
to give a reason every time because as
parents we'd be doing that all the time
yeah make sure you connect at least once
so that they know otherwise what will
kids tell you you've never told me I
never know this is a problem so you make
your request as any of us would want do
unto others be reasonable be friendly
give them a reason and being being nice
you're probably gonna remind them at
least once about it
hey remember yesterday when you came
home I said please put your coat
please take your backpack to room with
your homework materials I asked you not
to leave on the steps last reminder and
then respond so the next time is okay
remember we gave you the rule I gave
your mind it now here's your discipline
for that now the reason I'm saying this
is so often I've come across parents who
do request requests requests requests
reason reason reason reason reason
remind remind remind remind remind and
they have no clue of why the child
doesn't believe them because they've
gone so on trying to give detail
requests now Johnny if you don't hang up
your coat can you imagine what a
terrible life this will be you'll have
and you don't picture back packing room
what if someone trips over it your books
get damaged your homework gets damaged
your grades will go down you won't get
into Harvard you won't make a million
dollars and I won't be able to retire on
yours you know if we go off in these
things and sometimes as parents we go so
far with explanations really it's the
kind of thing that just human decency is
make your point and move on and so long
those lines it is important to respond
but notice also what I didn't say to do
was just respond and sometimes as
parents we do that I know my dad bless
his soul he used his son sometimes come
up with these rules at the moment
he'd say all right that does that I've
told you a thousand times not to do that
you're in trouble now and say Dan you
never said anything to me about remember
very clearly one time I was think I was
doing my homework
at the dining room table well the table
was being set by my sister and she of
course said dad Tim one move away from
the table I can't get the table set and
he comes in yelling how many times have
I told you not to do that well you learn
when you're dealing with fathers you
don't say you never told me this dad
it's you get up in your move but it is
one of those things that very often as
parents we have to make sure we're not
unreasonable and just suddenly snap and
respond you have to think it through and
the last thing is consistency
consistency is real important but you
have to stick with it now I'm not saying
we have to be so rigid and never allow
any change at all because sometimes life
throws you a curve and you have to adapt
but it is consistency that's so
important and especially with children
when they say well can I have us
exception today or do I have to pick
this up today or I was tired today
and you know it's so important we get
kids involved with the routine because
there will be times when you have to
make an exception
but if they're always the reason you're
making in the exception today is
tired and I don't really care like
enforcing it then what happens is
instead of your child paying attention
to the rules
they'll pay attention to your mood now
let's say of dads in a bad mood of moms
in a bad mood I'll listen but if they're
in a good mood or tired I can do
whatever I want and that's not a very
good strategy to learn in life because
then what kids learn is how to read the
eyes of their teachers and ignore the
rules unless their teacher looks upset
maybe if they get pulled over for
speeding they'll say well let me first
check out this policeman and see if he's
in a bad mood his bad mood I won't say
anything he's a good man I'll try and
sweet-talk him out of my break in the
law you're better off helping the kids
know that rules or rules it is an
important moral lesson for children to
understand that and in today's world
where I think kids are learning more of
a situation ethics and ignoring that
there can be rights and wrongs the best
lesson for that is a teaching there are
rights and wrongs there may be times and
as a parent you have to let things slide
a little bit
I won't enforce us right now while we're
standing in the middle of a store but
later on I will enforce this but it is
important that they know that there is
those kind of things now let me apply
this real quickly and then we'll take
some questions from you I want to apply
this to a couple of times during the day
I was some little potential meltdown
times and let's apply these rules a
little bit for example let's say kids
have a sloppy happen let's let's go
again with this idea Johnny comes home
from school he drops his jacket down
with a floor he drops his backpack on
the steps he runs up to his room and
you've said many times please stop doing
that well what's the good consequence
for that well I guess each time you
could simply call him downstairs and so
he learns the routine he comes in the
house he drops his jacket he drops his
backpack on the steps he goes up to his
room mom screamed to him get down here
and pick up your backpack how many times
have I told you to take care of this he
picks it up goes his room and the next
day the same thing happens Johnny come
down here get your backpack and he
learns that he doesn't really have to do
anything until mom screams and then
that's not what you really want so we
have to reprogram this computer
reprogram it how do you do that
see Johnny we're gonna reprogram it so
what we're gonna do is I'm gonna have
you took to your backpack and your
jacket put your jacket back on take your
backpack get out of the house come back
in the house when you come in the house
I want you to hang up your jacket
your backpack and walk it upstairs now
he'll think you're nuts but you've got
because why am I doing this it says well
cuz I don't like the old routine if I
yell at you everyday it doesn't seem to
be working that program is not working
so we're gonna have you come back and do
another thing so if Johnny is in this
age range probably around the 6:00 to
9:00 or 10:00 when he'll still cooperate
with something like that don't try this
with a 16 year old then you go ahead and
do it and he picks up the backpack and
jacket he goes back outside comes in
hangs up as Jack picks up his backpack
and goes upstairs is great now come on
back downstairs again and bring your
backpack with you
why because we're gonna do it again and
you have him do it through three four
times five times and he says enough mom
I got it okay I hope so because we tried
it five times today and I hope five
times works because if it doesn't work
tomorrow we'll go for ten now look what
you've done in that moment it doesn't
have to be insulting it doesn't have to
be attacking him personally and saying
you mean evil child I don't know where
you came from what planet how dare you
do this to me and mess up the home you
say they understand computer programming
and say we just have to retrain you and
that's part that actually is of an
important learning experience secondly
instead of just giving a child time out
go to your room or you're grounded sit
in the chair you're actually using this
as a teaching moment for the for the
child and do respectful and of course
the next day if he does it again
you tried 10 times I have found that
usually you don't have to go more than a
couple days in these situations with a
child a secondary I want to talk about
let's pick another thing sibling battles
I imagine some of you probably have more
than one child and they fight with each
other okay I see the I see the looks in
your eyes of fatigue and weariness one
of the things that happens here let me
describe a way that you can combine
communication skills and consequences
with children to help with sibling
battles typical scenario of course
siblings will find all sorts of ways to
fight pick on each other maybe once
sitting there quietly watching
television the other one comes through
change the channel on the TV as I was
watching this first why don't care what
I wanted to what you watch and they
fight back and forth they trip someone
they hit someone they hide their things
they oh I attend bows and sisters so we
learn all kinds of tricks in that in
that whole technique I mean my sister
one time I think got me by I complained
because the dishes weren't clean once
and
how she got me back before she put the
dishes on the table she rubbed dishes up
all over it
so that I would believe it was clean so
I next time she says there next time you
complain you wash it anyways it ended up
a little tougher than that you can
imagine but what happens in these
situations how do you deal with kids
fighting back and forth well parents I
have four different roles one is you can
do absolutely nothing you can just be a
bystander and let it go and sometimes
that is the best thing to do let them
work it out and you can even let them
know it says you guys work it out if one
of them comes to mom dented I think you
guys can handle this you know what to do
let them do it sometimes that'll work
now if it's getting out of control that
doesn't mean as a parent you simply run
and say I can't handle this I don't know
what to do if you believe they can work
it out be the bystander but don't
retreat away and let it elevate or
escalate up to some nasty level that's
not a good thing a second thing that can
happen and this is not a good thing
either is for the parents to become a
co-conspirator in the process so if
Little Billy comes up to you and says
mom Patrick is doing this to me he's
smacking me he's doing these things to
me don't say to Billy well you deserve
it because you've been driving me nuts
all day and you drive him nuts all day
and so if he beats you up then fine you
deserve it not a good idea
parents do that you use that one huh
well it's not a good idea cuz what
happens is didn't you're promoting the
children to go ahead and fight each
other that way I'll give you a couple of
techniques oh so you can try a different
one tonight how are your children that
you did it with I don't know if you like
that idea here's another one you can do
instead if they come to you and say mom
or dad this fights going on or you see
it going on you can be if you see it you
can be the referee now just like in a
hockey game the referee doesn't stand
around and wait and so another player
comes up you know the defenseman comes
up and says hey the center of the other
team just tripped me with a stick this
is well let's sit down and talk about it
now the referee says I saw it I blow the
whistle you penalty box
very simple referee doesn't need a
description they saw it so if indeed
to our example if you know one child is
watching TV quietly the other kids by
smacks on the head takes a remote
control change the channel you really
don't need deeps philosophical
discussions you know what happened you
did something wrong take over act
another technique you can use is to be
the judge now this is for those cases
when the child is describing something
to you that a little more elongated of
what is going wrong and it's a great
lesson for teaching kids how to pay
attention and how to describe what
happens especially since they'll come to
you anyways and they'll each tell their
side of the story and it goes on and on
and on and they'll interrupt each other
well treat it like the courtroom that
they want it to be give each of them a
chance to say what the issue is give
each one then this is okay now while
you're talking you have to be quiet and
then when you're talking you ought to be
quiet and then give me a chance to rebut
respond to that thing and say okay I've
heard both sides now now I'm gonna think
about this I'm gonna pass judgment aside
who's guilty or not and you can give
relative guilt when your parent it's not
all or not and I'm going to assign some
punishment to go with this and you can
do all that now what you're doing again
is you're teaching children to stop
think it through pay attention to all
the parts of with it and you're letting
them know there's consequences to them
and this is good one for children who
perhaps are younger Elementary School up
a little bit but let me describe a
technique you use for little older
elementary school and that's that play
the role of the teacher now the teacher
is different from the judge and that the
teacher gives them an assignment and
that is I want you to write down what
happened and not only do I want you to
write down what happen I want you to
write down what happened from your point
of view and from your brothers and
sisters point of view to let's take them
both you're trying to teach some empathy
and one of the things that happens with
kids who have a lot of anger and
difficulties they're not very good at
understanding themselves and they're
awful at understanding other people but
by getting them to write about it you're
really getting them to focus on some of
the differences here and then they not
only write about it but you say now I
want you to also offer a solution
because a good teacher will have the
child write a full essay could be
one-page two-page essay whatever it
takes
and once they describe the problem they
come up with a solution now many times
I've seen children's solutions be such
things as the solution is it'll never
happen again or the solution is
send Billy off to go to a live in
California or somebody that sent them
off to a nother school somewhere else
sign them up for the Marines whatever it
is if they do that I guess you can
accept that once unless they're sending
them off
but especially when kids say I'll never
do it again that's my solution you can
accept at once and as a teacher as the
teachers role you can decide whether or
not you're going to accept that paper
now this isn't you graded ABCD or F no
that's not acceptable parenting because
you're gonna say this is going to be
pass/fail and we're not gonna let you
fail because you don't get to really
complete this task
your task isn't over until I say it's
over so you have to rewrite it now I've
always admired teachers who do this
anyways if there's teachers listening
here one of the things that I know in
school is if children do a paper and
it's pretty bad and they get a D or they
get an F that's the end of it and what
the child learns as I did enough just to
get by or a failed and that's the end of
it but imagine what would happen if
teachers demanded more to says no you're
not a d student you're not a dumb kid
you know lazy kid I believe you can do a
B work and we're gonna rework this and
then you're gonna hand it as an a paper
and you're gonna get an A as opposed to
a D but so often we simply accept
mediocrity or less than mediocrity for
children and let it go and that's their
great where's parents we can't accept it
instead as parents we need to say if
it's not up to snuff you got to rewrite
this
you got to rework this you've got to
come up with a better plan of action now
what this becomes is this whole extended
timeout with work involved while the
child's doing this they're not outside
playing ball with their friends and not
watching TV they're not on the computer
they're doing another task for you and a
number of things have come out of this
number one the kid will say I don't want
to have this problem again because I
don't want to spend my time writing so
much but two there's a lesson to learn
here and it's so important as parents we
communicate these lessons to children as
so often we don't so often children
instead learned stay away from mom she's
in bad moods stay away from daddy had a
bad day at work or he's gonna get worst
punishments and mom and that's what they
learn and they learned to avoid the
person who could enforce as opposed to
do the right thing and when they learn
there is not so much even situation
ethics they learned to hide from the
policeman to stay away from trouble that
it's okay to do this as long as there's
no chance you're gonna get caught that's
not the lesson we want to teach kids in
life
lest we want to teach them is there our
rights and wrongs and you're gonna live
with that and that helps you a great
deal now this does not mean kids will
still not do things to drive you crazy
because they will because they are
that's actually some of the joy of
childhood as well as from the
frustrations of parenting they come up
with lots of creative solutions and if
you can stop sometimes and think about
those and laugh about those you can
survive as long as you don't take them
all personal but it is important though
that you have a network of friends to
rely on a spouse and other people and
that you also have a system whereby you
can apply it to handling discipline with
children and handling some those
problems not everything is handled the
same way but by having the system in
place you can really make some pretty
remarkable gains with kids now what I
thought I'd do is maybe take some
questions from you about some situation
or some issues that you may have and
many times I should tell you many times
parents don't want to talk about their
own children so go ahead and tell me
about someone you know you know the
child next door does this and will help
that parent next door then instead of
you if you don't want to specifically
ask about your own kids anything yes go
ahead Tim there is a tremendous peer
pressure at school
for kids to gravitate toward mediocrity
particularly boys it's not cool to study
it's not cool to be smart and get good
grades how does a parent handle it and
help the kid overcome overcome that well
you're right it is a trend many times in
many schools that there is this pressure
that if you study too hard you're a geek
and something wrong with you
luckily there has been some responses
back from the geeks of the world who say
you know they grow up to be billionaires
and there's positive things there and it
is so important that from the early
years parents let kids know the value of
doing a good job and help understand
that for the future it's not enough just
it you should never tie it in that
you're worth something if you do well
and you're not worth something you don't
do well because then what children
gravitate towards when they're
especially when they're preteen and
teenagers is simply the you can the
feelings of their peers because they've
tied their whole self-esteem into in
that person's perception what's
important is to get children to think
about the value of who they are as a
person and the value for their future
many times kids in fifth and sixth grade
for example deal with a tremendous
amount of peer pressure and then worries
about what kids think about them there's
a lot more gossip that takes place
between children and it can be very very
painful as a parent sometimes some of
the best things you can say to young
children is you know the good news is
sixth grade doesn't last forever it does
end and that the kids who are doing this
to you now will be kids who you may
never again see in life we got to make
it through this year that's part another
thing is to get them involved in some
activities where is important and
valuable for them every flower has its
season and sometimes like the crocus in
the spring the first one some kids do
bloom early and a lot of successes early
and some kids like the chrysanthemum
much later in their school life before
they start to blossom and some things
they can do well and it's important to
find ways that the child can blossom if
even if not in school so the child who
may be struggling with something to
school maybe there's other things they
can do outside maybe through music maybe
through theatre maybe through the arts
maybe through sports something away from
that same set of kids so that not always
with us the same ones they can find an
island
of respite and island of hope and island
of success somewhere else for them and
in that you're gonna consciously
building in them that the sense of
looking towards their future and looking
towards their own talents of things they
they can't succeed and it's an ongoing
battle but it is one that parents cannot
ignore and sometimes we do ignore
because kids will withdraw within
themselves and sometimes find very bad
peers to hang around with because I'll
say well I'll just shift away and I'll
get my hope from somewhere else and then
parents find themselves hearing about
ugly stuff their child has done because
they let it go yes stay engaged another
question in the back yes
14 and he spends a lot of time in front
of the computer yeah and also reading
but you know the computer issue is one
that in our society and I remember as I
gave given talks over the years five ten
years ago it was unheard of and now
children are practically living with
their computers either surfing the net
which is it can be dangerous or on on
going chat rooms or with instant
messaging each other often times five
six ten different people at the same
time first of all and the issue of
surfing the net it is extremely
important that you know what kids are
doing at all times
they make programs where you can monitor
that where you can check up later and
see what websites your child was on you
can block certain things from your
computer but it's also important don't
put computers in your children's rooms
keep them in visible places in the
kitchen in the living room not with the
screen hidden so you can't see it we
have one in our TV room screens facing
the rest of the room and much to my
daughter's dismay we can see everything
she's looking at now she's good she
doesn't do anything bad there but it is
but it but many times that's a concern
like in public libraries sometimes
people concerned but what are their kids
looking on the web well you know when
you have a separate room that no one can
see in a computer room orange in schools
then you're going to have that on the
other hand if it's are sitting right
there next to where the librarian can
see it kids will be a lot nicer but it
but that's number one number two it is
appropriate to limit the amount of time
especially if you're finding that your
child is spending so much of their time
on the computer and not getting out of
the house get out and play get some
exercise do things that is so important
you know we talked about I'm sure you've
heard the news about the increasing
health problems among children the
obesity rates up to 20% or so huge
problems among children with with that
they're not eating right they're not
exercising right and they're having
other problems there's a tiny just turn
it off now many of the addicted child
will start fighting you at that point
you can't turn this off I've got to talk
to my friends and in many cases it's
just someone down the street get
together do something it's important
that you push them to do that as a
parent there's a lot of good that can
come out a computer certainly the
research that comes out of the writing
skills and everything
but they're not learning a lot of great
writing schools and they're learning a
language of misusing monosyllabic or
singular words and it's all the same
language and if you ever watch with it
right back and forth no that makes much
sense anyways but you know quite frankly
it's probably the same kind of goofiness
we talked about on the phone for hours
when we were teenagers the same kind of
things but it is a it is appropriate to
keep an eye on that and to limit it you
two questions one in each kind of school
there is possible so the high schooler
he's starting 10th grade
I'd like to have a method by which I
could get him a little more even keel I
mean he'll have his highs they'll have
his loads I know he's got hormones and
all that other stuff going on which try
to atribute it too but I kill be nice
and a regular kid and then the other
times I just go excuse me could you let
my son out and and I'd like to know if
there's a way to try to pull him back
into being the kind of child I know he
is no man that I
so he can be a fine charming the dr.
Jekyll mr. Hyde kind of things with
teens
well you're right first of all
understanding the teenagers have these
kind of white mood swings it's part
hormonal it's part growing up it's just
part the craziness they don't know who
they are anymore they are so concerned
also of do people accept them to the
girls boys wonder if the girls liking
girls one of the boys like them they're
trying to decide with so much they're
trying to discover by themselves they
know they're no longer kid but they have
no clue how to be a man or a woman and
yet trying to put on the act and when
you call him on that they don't like it
very much because it's so frail I think
Mark Twain said it best once he said
something along the lines of um when he
was 17 he thought his father was a
dumbest man in the world but by the time
he turned 21 he was it was remarkable
how smart his father had gotten in those
four years and that is gonna happen with
with teenagers there's a few basics you
need to continue to do over the years
make sure your teen knows that you still
love them now it is hard to do that
sometimes and we all forget that
but it's real important to let them know
you find those kind of things when I
talked about things you'd like to stay
the same
and maybe it's not going to be he's
gonna be the cuddly little son who once
climbed on your lap and had you read
them stories anymore but there's still
those kind moments when you think and
when you tell him and sometimes you just
for no reason all you tell him you're
great kid I like what you do that's good
a second thing is and here's what can be
very valuable as parents go ahead and
let them know this is a tough time
if you liked your Chalobah tit whoever
and you say you know a typical thing for
children of your ages you'll have
hormonal problems and sometimes you'll
be crazy and sometimes not and we didn't
want to add a lecture nor do they want
to hear you go on with you know when I
was a child if I ever did this my father
would smack me upside the head but
sometimes I got you again but sometimes
in yeah that's the moves but sometimes
you can have fun with the idea of an
anecdote now not all the time yeah but
now then you can slip a little story it
like when you're driving captive
audience number one never to never do
this in front of your child's France
because they'll get embarrassed dad
please know another story but sometimes
you can slip something in now I use the
story once with my daughter about I went
to the worst prom in the world I mean it
was awful and I will spare you the
details of that but it was a miserable
time and it was so bad it was funny and
so I said no matter what happens to you
I don't when you're going on a date they
can't possibly as miserable as all the
mistakes and the car problems and the
being late and and everything that
happened with this sort of a thing or
sometimes it's good to tell about
embarrassing moments you've had not to
the point where your child thinks you're
a complete idiot
but at least the point reach out knows
you make mistakes and you survive and
it's important you have that resolution
the resolution support not again not so
your child says oh gosh I'm so
embarrassed I hope you never do this
again in life but to say you know you
make a mistake and you survive and
that's the lesson and it isn't such a
bad thing
those little anecdotes can be real
valuable in those quiet moments
one-on-one with your son you can let me
know those kind of things you know Dad
can do those things too you know you let
them know now dead men are oftentimes
very unexpressive and but if you never
made mistakes when you're younger it
won't work right well make up some if
you're creative you may make up a story
yeah give him a few what about other men
you've dated any final yes is it my
imagination or is just more
documentation or better testing but are
there more angry children
than they used to be just like some
forms of cancer is it not necessarily
that there's more of it which have
better ways of detecting it and plena
fiying what what has happened in our
society that has produced angry children
I actually think that there with regard
to anger I think there is more anger
among children now one if one does
studies about crimes by children you
will have found 50 years ago 100 years
ago that there was some child that took
the family gone out or attacked someone
or harm someone that part is not
necessarily new but the incidences we
see of the kind of things kids do by
their behaviors in the broad spectrum I
think there is a lot more anger and I
think there's a number of reasons for
that first of all I think children are
spending less time with adults and that
is so important you see study after
study that shows that children who spend
time positive time in adult supervised
activities are much better off lower
drug and alcohol problems lower
incidents of risky driving with the cars
lower rates of premarital sex or
pregnancy rates when kids do these kind
of things and that could be anything
could be church groups it can be ban it
can be Boy Scouts it could be
after-school activities any of those
things can be valuable with them but
kids are not spending that time more and
more there at home with their computers
or just with other kids with very little
adults around secondly the kind of
influences they have such as the media a
child by the time they are 18 will have
probably spend about 15,000 hours in
front of the television and 11,000 hours
in school now during that 15 thousand
hours you can go to law school and
medical school and probably finish your
residency it's a significant amount of
time but children watching TV and note
that most the TV programs - a number of
things they probably watch a hundred
thousand acts of violence maybe hundred
thousand murders or other things but in
addition it's a lot of sarcasm a lot of
humor based upon ridiculing someone else
you don't see any comedies on TV where
the father really has any clue what's
going on do you can you think of any
positive fatherly role and a television
sitcom you can't the father's a buffoons
mothers usually had a little more
intelligence and they
they have some things but they'll make
their mistakes too but using the mothers
in the Rolla since he's getting humour
is if father's a dumb guy and the
mothers turn to do things too and the
kids are always smart mouths I guess it
wouldn't be entertaining if the children
actually talked civil to one another but
it's always pranks and nastiness and
meanness that go on with these things so
when you combine a lot of this together
and then combine it too with a lot of
the video games and internet influence
the kids have there's so many negative
influences it is tough it is very tough
on kids to survive that and what they
see is a lot of reinforcement and a lot
of role modeling for being angry and for
lashing out that is why and if there's
nothing else you remember from anything
I say it is so important that parents
are engaged in their children's lives as
I said at the outset of my talk there's
the solutions to dealing with anger the
solutions deal with any parenting
problem can't come from the US House
can't come from your state house can
only come from your house and what we
have to do is reconnect with children's
lives and stop looking for someone else
to do it stop blaming the teacher stop
blaming the principal it's not blaming
the parents the kid next door but look
to our own children and say what can I
do to help my child do better and it
doesn't come from being a parent who is
aloof and distant and not engaged to be
that aloof and distant parent who's not
engaged means we will consciously be
looking at someone else to take care of
our kids for us we'll be going to the
school board we go into the principal
and teachers and say why don't you take
care of this and that teacher I'll
guarantee it feels disconnected because
then they feel the parent isn't really
being a parent and standing up there
simply looking at the teacher to be a
babysitter and a caregiver and that's
not it they're not policemen they're
there to teach they have a vital and
wonderful role in life and that's what
we need to nurture but that means all of
us as parents and in our world and
certainly within the microcosm our
family have got to reconnect it is um
and I'll close with this thought you
know in in the life of a parent there's
a lot of ups and downs that we face a
lot of difficult times but for the most
part at the end of the day when your
child's going off to college or your
child's move it out of the house I'll
have to work you know a tear is shed
because the good times that way the bad
times because you recognize your
chowder's learn some pretty remarkable
things in life and you're happy about
that and it really comes down to that if
you live your life as a parent as
if you will make a difference in the
life of a child indeed you will indeed
you will and that is what I hope we all
gain from this as parents that there's a
huge need that children have for us to
be adults again and be parents again and
if we do we will have rediscovered fire
thanks so much Tim Murphy represents the
18th congressional district of
Pennsylvania in the US House the angry
child is published by Three Rivers press
an imprint of Random House visit Random
House dot-com for more information